depuis quand ça existe le congé
paternité en france tout commence en
1946 c'est alors un congé de naissance
de trois jours
mais dès les années 70 il est jugé trop
court par certaines femmes qui prône une
meilleure répartition des tâches entre
les parents si on veut que la femme soit
l'égal de l'homme dans le travail et sur
le plan de la carrière et de la
promotion il soit que l'homme soit
l'égal de la femme chez lui dans son
sang dans son foyer pour les travaux
domestiques mais également pour
l'éducation des enfants et même des
jeunes hommes pour certains papas un
congé plus long permettrait aussi de
mieux s'investir dans l'éducation de
leurs enfants et ça dès les premiers
mois des nouveaux papas comme il était
appelé par les médias perçus comme des
extraterrestres écoutez le ton de cette
journaliste en 1981
c'est peut-être l'émancipation féminine
qui entraîne l'évolution des pères mais
ce que toutes les femmes vont accepter
que les hommes empiète sur leurs
prérogatives et leur vole un peu de
leurs enfants
les années passent et les hommes n'ont
toujours que les fameux trois jours à la
naissance de leur enfant
pourtant les mentalités ont évolué
ce n'est plus des virilisant comme
certains le pensent et est de plus en
plus de jeunes pères dénonce cette
absence de congé il faudra attendre les
années 2000 et le gouvernement jospin
pour que la france mette en place un
congé paternité
bonjour consécutif à prendre dans les
mois suivant la naissance prise en
charge à 100% par la sécurité sociale
il marque la reconnaissance du rôle du
père
au cours de la petite enfance instaure
une parité parentale qui est un nouveau
progrès dans l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes qui vous le savez est au
coeur de la politique gouvernementale
les auteurs de la loi espérer que 40%
des nouveaux papas et recourent à ce
congé
ce fut en fait 60 % des jeunes pères qui
se sont absentés du travail en 2002 pour
s'occuper de leur bébé
il souhaiterait jouer peu importe on
vous le dit il prend conscience de son
être et de sa famille qui le fit
beaucoup aujourd'hui cette paire sur dix
ont recours à leur congé paternité
et d'après le ministère de la santé les
pères qui prennent ce congé sans dans
une famille où les rôles de la femme et
de l'homme sont les moins différenciés
un congé paternité vecteur d'égalité
dans le couple c'est pourquoi plusieurs
associations et les jeunes français
eux-mêmes souhaite un rallongement du
congé paternité à un mois
[Musique]